what was Hillary Clinton's biggest lie
during the democratic debate the idea
that whistleblower Edward Snowden could
have gone through official channels
Edward Snowden is he a traitor or hero
he broke the laws of the United States
he could have been a whistleblower he
could have gotten all of the protections
of being a whistleblower he could have
raised all the issues that he has raised
and I think there would have been a
positive response to that recent TV
recently talked with jesselyn radack of
exposed faqs org she's the lawyer for
Edward Snowden and other high-profile
whistleblowers for all the people out
there shouting that Edward Snowden
should have gone through the proper
channels first of all they're not that
many channels for national security and
intelligence whistleblowers they are
excluded from most avenues available to
other whistleblowers but second of all
Tom Drake and bill Binney Kirk Wiebe
Annette Loomis did go through the proper
channels and all of them fell under
criminal investigation for having done
stuff Clinton has a right to her own
opinion about the value and damage done
by Edward Snowden's revelations but
she's simply not credible when she says
that he could have worked through
official channels